si vous ne pensez pas qu'il y a de l'espoir pour le
monde
[Applaudissements]
Je ne sais pas,
continuez pour la famille
Je ne suis pas une famille, pas de
cargaison
[Musique]
Pourquoi êtes-vous si important
Quelque part dans l'Ouest, ils travaillent sur un
remède, je pense  ce qui les a vraiment impressionnés,
c'est le fait que je ne me suis pas transformé en
monstre que vous voyez autant que des contractions d'
accord,
je vous emmène avec moi,
faites ce que je dis quand je le dis,
vous avez des conseils sur le meilleur chemin vers l'ouest
ouais allez vers l'est
tu es venu jusqu'ici
et tu sais ce qu'il y a là-bas
tu ne vas pas nous faire
peur lui a fait peur